merci beaucoup difficile pas terminé
mais difficile c'est un sommet qui
semble s'éterniser officiellement prévu
pour durer deux jours les négociations
entre les 27 dirigeants de l'ue se
poursuivre
une quatrième journée pour tenter de
trouver un accord sur un plan de relance
post coronavirus sur la table des
négociations un fonds constitué par une
capacité d'emprunt de 750 milliards
d'euros composé de 250 milliards d'euros
de prêts et surtout des dons à hauteur
de 500 milliards qui n'auront pas être
remboursés par les états bénéficiaires
le montant de ces derniers devraient
être revues à la baisse avec une
nouvelle proposition basée sur un
montant de subvention de 390 milliards
d'euros face à certaines dissensions
celle des pays dits frugaux l'autriche
le danemark les pays bas et la suède
tous les quatre demandent que l'aide
financière ne soit plus donné mais prêté
et avec l'obligation pour les états de
présenter leurs plans de relance
nationaux devant lieux des différents
qui fragilise l'alliance politico
économique selon le médiateur du sommet
charles michel
la question est la suivante les
vingt-sept leaders responsables devant
les peuples européens sont ils capables
de bâtir de l'unité de la confiance ou
bien à travers une déchirure
présenteront nous le visage d'une robe
faibles minées par la défiance
malgré les efforts répétés de paris et
berlin les leaders de l'ue eux peinent à
trouver un compromis
le président français semble tout de
même satisfait de l'avancée des
négociations
nous avons beaucoup avancé sur les
sujets de règles de fonctionnement de du
fonds de relance des éléments d'avancé
se sont matérialisés durant la nuit pour
essayer de trouver un accord sur le
montant total du fonds de relance et la
part de subvention comme vous le savez
est le sujet le plus sensible sans doute
des derniers jours des dernières heures
il y a un esprit de compromis qui est là
il ya eu des moments très tendu il y a
des moments les moments qui seront sans
doute encore difficile mais sur ce sujet
les choses ont avancé faut maintenant
qu'on rentre dans le détail de ce qui
sera la nouvelle proposition
les partis sont néanmoins confiante sur
la possibilité de trouver un accord au
cours des prochaines heures
nous n'avons pas encore trouvé d'issue
cela peut encore échouer mais je suis
plus optimiste que je ne l'étais cette
nuit à un moment donné où je me suis dit
c'est fini
les négociations ne sont pas encore
terminées elles se poursuivront
prochainement mais cela fait maintenant
trois jours que nous négocions dernier
cycle de négociations c'est qu'ils se
déroulent maintenant dimanche a duré
plus de 20 heures
mais nous pouvons être très satisfaits
nous avons réussi à réduire
considérablement le monde au total
les rabais autrichien augmenterait
fortement il est important que les
négociations se poursuivent à bruxelles
cela montre que tout le monde veut une
solution mais d'énormes efforts sont
nécessaires pour rendre l'europe à
nouveau solidaire le coc u19 nous a tous
secoué la solidarité entre tous les
états portera ses fruits
ces derniers jours c'est l'avenir de
l'europe qui se joue à bruxelles ainsi
que la capacité du couple
franco-allemand à unifier une union
européenne qui ressort très affaiblie
par la crise sanitaire